coûte vous savez que ce matin une très
grosse opération de police a été menée 1
planoise il ya eu quinze interpellations
des policiers sont venus de dijon de
nancy et d'ailleurs pour arrêter donc
des gens à planoise
on va écouter tout de suite le l'un des
syndicalistes de la police municipale de
besançon il s'appelle ivan d'écrouer on
écoute il a une question à vous poser
bonjour madame bonjour messieurs je me
présente yvon de couy délégué syndical
force ouvrière à la pm de besançon et
j'aurai une question à vous poser dans
le climat d' angélisme actuel et au vu
des faits réels qui se passe sur le
terrain dans la ville de besançon des
morts des trafics diverses et des
incivilités qui gêne considérablement la
vie des bisontins et byzantine
j'aimerais savoir quels seront vos
orientations pour la sécurité et la
tranquillité plus vite qui sont du
ressort du maire de besançon et quels
moyens humains et matériels vous mettrez
à disposition donc en parlant de
sécurité donc ce syndicaliste parle de
climat d'angélisme
vous en avez parlé vous même de
l'angélisme tout à l'heure est ce que
vous vous sentez visé
et qu'est ce que vous mettez comme
moyens humains et matériels à la police
nationale à la police municipale pardon
alors du coup on a fait une introduction
avec la police nationale
oui donc j'aimerais revenir quand même
sur cet épisode qui n'est pas rien
d'être anodin parce que vous savez très
bien que j'avais pris une position très
très forte qui consistait à dire l'état
doit être présent doit nous appelons dès
cette protection
je les salue et je salue le travail qui
fait pas recette police nationale
c'est fondamental ce sont des vrais
professionnels de la criminalité on est
d'accord
ensuite pour la question de l'incivilité
là on est sur d'autres critères et moi
j'ai travaillé très fortement avec
l'ensemble des syndicats j'ai rencontré
tous les syndicats de la police
municipale en leur promettant que nous
retravaillerons sur leur mission parce
que il est important déjà en premier
temps de savoir qui fait quoi
très bien ludovic fagots à propos de la
police nationale et municipale enfin
police nationale je suis ravi que madame
vigneault salue la police nationale
d'où votre présence certainement la
manifestation à l'encontre des policiers
nationaux de samedi donc pas je vais pas
sur ce sujet contextualise comme on dit
à savoir samedi avec des manifestations
anti violence policière madame vigneault
vous y étiez
alors moi je suis arrivé au
rassemblement parce que en même temps je
suis membre de la ligue des droits de
l'homme depuis très longtemps et je
défends une chose c'est le respect je
respecte les policiers je suis très
respectueuse des policiers pour autant
ça ne nous empêche pas de rappeler qu'
il y a des choses qui ne peuvent pas
arriver et c'était ce à la demande de ce
rassemblement le récit fallait que
j'explique il fallait que j'explique
pourquoi ludovic phaneuf
vous parlez d'une manifestation samedi
alors moi si vous voulez moi je ne
serais pas du côté de la théorie de
l'excusé si vous avez bien compris par
rapport à par rapport à cela
la situation aujourd'hui n'est plus
forcément sous contrôle à besançon le
sait on le voit les incivilités et les
insécurités gâche le quotidien des des
bisontines et des bisontins et je le
redis moi je serai le maire de la
sécurité de tous pour l'ensemble des
incivilités de l'insécurité sur le
territoire bisontin donc ça passe par
différents éléments
puisqu'il faut pouvoir protéger nos
familles nos policiers municipaux qui se
retrouve face à ses 15 qui ont été
arrêtés ce matin où c'est de la grande
délinquance sont des gens lourdement
armés donc il faut recruter former et
armer nos policiers municipaux ce qu'on
a toujours défendu pendant ce mandat
mais c'est également doublé donc les
effectifs de nos policiers municipaux
s'est également déployé la visio
protection la vidéoprotection sur sur le
territoire et de redonner à nos
policiers municipaux donc des missions
de maintien de tranquillité publique
pour pouvoir permettre vous êtes police
nationale secours que celui de jacques
richard des ti du rassemblement national
n'ont effectué partie la sécurité c'est
comme l'écologie ça n'appartient pas à
tel ou tel parti
on a toujours été constant par rapport à
cela contrairement à d'autres ici sur le
plateau parce qu'on a vraiment nous
cette constance par rapport à l'armement
n'a vraiment c'est là justement par
rapport à longré 13 ans plus tard ceux
des crises et des trésors d'art
entreprises ont su de les bisons c'est
vous qui est visé quand vous étiez chez
des verts vous n'étiez pas très pro
police armée là c'est quoi le sujet
privilégié ce n'était pas le sujet
privilégié loin de là
pourquoi aujourd'hui vous êtes sur la
même ligne que jacques richard petty
donc jean mallet du rassemblement
national ou ludovic fagots du tout mais
vous voulez armée la plus belle faut
regarder les choses un peu plus un peu
plus au fond si vous permettez faut
avoir les yeux ouverts sur la situation
tient le délitement du lien social
la perte du respect mutuel du respect
des enseignants parfois par les enfants
et même vers le parent par les parents
la perte des respects des policiers
qu'ils soient nationaux ou municipaux
qui se font insulter provoqué craché au
visage
c'est un juste intolérables et à force
de dépasser sans arrêt les limites de
soi disant la liberté n'y a pas de
limite ya des limites à la liberté
et moi je veux être le maire il doit
restaurer la justice il doit restaurer
et de restaurer le respect mutuel il
doit respirer restaurer le respect des
valeurs
voilà et j'y suis absolument déterminé
pour cela évidemment le rôle primordial
des parents j'aurais des contrats de
parentalité avec les parents dont les
enfants ont fait des bêtises avec les
enseignants les éducateurs en général
qu'est ce que les aguerris des bêtises
des bêtises bagdad la délinquance des
délits des délits oui c'est ça c'est dit
au niveau des grosses bêtises alors des
grosses bêtises web pas des bêtises est
quoi des groupes armés mais à partir des
petites bêtises on partir des petites
bêtises
visiblement vous êtes à peu près sur la
même longueur d'onde que monsieur phal
moi je sais je sais pas où et monsieur
fagots je sais ce que je veux pour cette
ville voilà et donc je veux du respect
mutuel entre les uns et les autres mais
ça passe ça passe sur les objets qu'on
jette sur la voie publique tiens ça
voudrait dire à vos équipes qui ramasse
les affiches quand il est arraché face à
130 euros
mais là dessus s'est passé à 130 euros
les affiches et qui sont quand même très
haut respecte donc pour demander qui
causait tant qu'il est qui qui fait des
délits paye vous serez peut-être à
monter ses biens dont le porte bon ça la
connaît la fierté et en ont fait pas de
la rigolade et vous faire des ennemis
deviennent coup fait fait en sorte d pas
des manières l'espace palmer
parallèlement aux parents rôle des
parents qui est primordial des
enseignants des éducateurs des
médiateurs que la police et des
roulements faut renforcer qu'elle
travaille de nuit qu'elle travaille
beaucoup plus dans les quartiers en lien
avec la police municipale et c'est tout
ça ne vous paraît la police nationale et
la police nationale pour se protéger
pour inspirer le respect auquel
prenaient une autre
j'ai eu des revers côté ravivant sur un
véhicule monsieur fabre bon attendez bon
il faut que la police ait des missions
renforcées et c'est dans ce cadre là que
il me semble impératif indispensable que
le maire de vaudou d'un court d'ailleurs
martial bourquin qu'il ya des maires de
gauche qui on sait pas c'est pas la
propriété de l'extrême droite je regarde
les choses en face de façon objective je
suis libre de tout dogme qu'il soit de
droite ou de gauche et j'avance vous
pour le bien des bisontins pour la
sécurité et les autres enjeux madame
vigneault oui je voulais juste a ajouté
que nous là la préoccupation nous avons
c'est les jeunes enfants qui se font
appeler par la criminalité
doc il est certain qu'il faut mettre
tout en oeuvre pour que les familles ne
se retrouve pas seul face à l'économie
parallèle qui s'est mis en place
donc il ya la police nationale qui
s'occupe de cette économie parallèle et
nous on a l'obligation d'accompagner les
familles qui sont en difficulté quand
leurs enfants se font ap donc on a les
animateurs de rue on a bien sûr les
maisons de quartier on a évidemment tout
ce que je suis rien à faire